it's April 1996 and it's time for lunch
Bill Clinton is the president Celine
Dion's because you loved me is on its
fifth week at number one on the
billboards and tremors two is currently
in theaters the bell just rang and
lunchtime for you might have looked like
this and if not for you then for that
other kid who always got the good
punches Bob can you hear me
like in Bob Green was a lead on the team
that developed Lunchables it was a real
blast from beginning to end but the mean
he says didn't come easily so we had a
bunch of names little Oscars bunch vixen
cracker witches gold packs snackable
mini meals lunch Express until they
landed on a name that truly defined a
generation we ended up with Lunchables
[Music]
okay if we had to pick one word that
define 90s drinks it would probably be
squeezable between kool-aid bursts Capri
Sun squeezes and mondo there was a lot
of market we all kind of came out at the
same time that's Ken hey it's kind of
like their president at JAL sir the
company that made mondo first question
we want to know about the cap well it
was a child protective cap it couldn't
be swallowed right I guess when I was
younger it just seemed way cooler than
an anti choking design but it was really
all about fun and flavor and I think
kind of in some ways a legendary product
that desert quick sidenote dunkaroos are
no longer in production and try as we
might and we tried hard we could not
find any anywhere for sale so this it's
just a printout we're sorry okay back to
the script stunk crews were king in the
lunchroom and the ads were iconic that I
paid my bills in the mid 90s with
voiceovers that's John Cameron Mitchell
writer of Hedwig and the Angry
and you might recognize him from girls
shrill or Mozart in the jungle
[Music]
he was the kangaroo in the dunkaroos
commercial I basically kind of imitated
robin Leach you know large cells of the
rich confinement so I get a very bad
Australian accent when I said had he do
yields Anka Roos and later worked with
Nicole Kidman and did it fur and she's
like not very good and there it is your
lunch and some of the people behind it
in 1996
[Applause]
[Music]